[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
Billy what is it Tom Kelly Marisa I know
I saw they're just sitting to my left
hand
it's going so well I'm so excited to be
here we've been trying to do this for a
while now Kelly Murphy oh I'm sorry no
no I'm not saying it so that you
apologize well she's difficult to get
hold of it she's a very popular person
very popular both professionally and
socially yes pulled in a whole bunch of
different directions but we've probably
been doing this podcast now for a couple
of years and I think within the first
couple of months I said to you hey Kelly
Marie we'd love to have you on and you
were like great I'm working and then
another time I'm working another time
but we got you we're here
come on because you say that you're good
friends and it doesn't seem that you're
good we are good friends are you really
we are good friends we actually the Hat
Madame is wearing I also aren't yeah we
have matching hats yes we're good
friends tell me about the Hat tell me
Well the hat is it's a it's a JJ Abrams
original so the working title for uh the
Star Wars film that I was in uh was
Trixie because if you take off the first
couple of letters and is it that the
last two letters it becomes IX which is
the Roman numerals for nine obviously
and we were episode nine that's the one
you were at as a Skywalker pretty cool
is that right calamari yes yes I was in
episode eight as well for people who are
not big Star Wars fans eight and nine
were made by JJ Abrams right correct and
that was the last ones that were made
correct us hold on seven and nine seven
and nine were JJ episode 8 was rad
Johnson yeah who we also love and adore
yeah okay and then one two and three one
two and three George Lucas yep four five
and six four George Lucas five
okay hang on Johnny's director
it's something like Irwin Cassady and
Duran
John is uh the director of Empire
Strikes
while we're preambling who who well
wasting time who directed return of July
no
tell me about that from the start how
how was
how did that come about that you've
found yourself in the Star Wars
yeah it was a a miracle I guess
um I was in LA working as an office
assistant and auditioning for a bunch of
stuff and not getting a lot of things
but getting close to certain things and
when I say things I mean like
commercials or like small parts on
sitcoms that I was auditioning for I
would have to go in like twice for like
a one-line role like it was like you
know I was I very much felt like I was
starting out but at the same time it
took me years to get to the point where
I was just auditioning I'm sure you both
know
um so I was sort of just auditioning I
was doing improv with friends at night
and like getting into sketch comedy I
was doing some sketches with college
humor at the time
um and then I started auditioning for
what was being referred to as this
Untitled Ryan Johnson project
um which then became episode eight uh
and I I thought it was like kind of a
joke the whole time I remember being
like oh this is hilarious like I'll tell
my grandkids one day that I auditioned
for this thing that I'm absolutely never
gonna get like it's just insane
um but I was wrong but did you know it
was Star Wars when it was called the
Untitled so it was supposed to be this
huge secret but it was pretty easy to
like Google what Ryan Johnson was
working on at the time right um yeah so
I figured it out uh uh but there was not
really any sort of information available
in terms of like what the movie was
about what the character was like
everything was so vague
um yeah it's a weird thing as an actor
right that
if you have one auditioning you don't
get it you kind of like used to that and
you're like okay cool that's just
another week but if you have four or
five auditions for the same thing and
you start to get invested it's so much
harder to forget that you know because
you've gone down I don't know about you
but like if I get to that point I'm
starting to think about how would they
walk how would they take their tea how
would they how would they be in the
morning what are they like when they're
drinking what how are they to their mum
and dad and stuff and then you have to
just forget all that if you don't get
the point yeah it's so I feel like
acting is so unhealthy for that reason
yeah right like it's just you have no
control over your life and you have to
sort of at least for me I feel like it's
been this journey of
of really trying to protect my
creativity and protect the love that I
have for the actual Act of it because
otherwise it's just too hard and it's
too scary and it's too uncertain
um I love to hear what it's been like
for both of you like how you're no I
totally agree it makes me think that
saying that Bryan Cranston said did you
see that or he's talking about it and he
says where it changed in his mind he
said something like I used to go to
audition scene pick me for this you know
I want to get this and then he changed
that to this is what I can offer you
this is you gave me these lines I I
could do this yeah and it will be good
and there there's what I'm offering and
it's up to you it doesn't matter to me
whether you say yes or no this is what I
think from those words this is here's an
option oh great and I thought that's
brilliant rather than because if you go
in with the I want this job you end up
not really making a decision decision on
how you're playing the character you're
too busy thinking what do they want what
would they like whereas if you go and
saying this is what I'm doing if you
think that's what you want then that's
great if you don't then that's yeah
that's great maybe you want someone
that's six you want something else
there's nothing that I can do about the
fact that I'm five foot seven and you
want someone that's six foot two that's
a really healthy way to approach it I
think and Billy and I laugh about this
thing all the time which is which is
such an interesting like examination of
actors
a lot of the time you get a job
you get your script you get your
schedule and the first thing that you
look at in your schedule is when's my
first day off
breaking ourselves to get a job and then
you're like oh cool I'm off on Tuesday
that's fantastic
so I've I've started to really kind of
try and change that narrative for me
which is I always wanted to be an actor
when I was a kid I've I've managed to
carve out a career as an actor and if
I'm lucky enough to be going to work
it's my favorite day otherwise you waste
months of your life going oh I can't
wait to finish so that I can go on
holiday and then you go on holiday and
you're like oh I'd really like to be
working like you need to be in that
place enjoy it you know yeah act as a
big complainers right a group of actors
is called a complaint event and then we
go off in tangents you'll notice yeah so
in case we do go off on tangents I just
want to say I absolutely loved your
character in those movies it was it and
I'm in this totally truthfully it's when
you see someone and in a movie and
you're just always wanting the camera to
go back to them that's how I feel about
your character and I think that may be
because you were doing improv and all
that it's just you talking there you had
that immediacy to your your character
that I was like oh it's exciting every
time we go there and that is a brilliant
thing you see on screen I think which is
adorable Rose yeah wonderful character
and you brought so so much to life well
there's a lot of there's a lot of
characters in the Star Wars universe
that are kind of capable that maybe
they're on the dark side or the light
side but they can handle it you know
like Han Solo can handle it Luke
Skywalker can handle it Chewbacca
there's not you know Darth Vader's kind
of tough they're all like they're on
either sides of the angle but they're
all like I'm here I can shoot a weapon I
can get into a fight I'm fine and what I
loved about what you found with rose is
there's a Humanity to it there's a
vulnerability you're like oh God I
really hope that she's okay you know
like you can see that that kind of
trepidation in your character yeah and
what's going on vulnerability
vulnerability in a dangerous well that
anything could happen and that's always
kind of you know in any act and that's a
a brilliant thing
your business can't keep
I dream higher
you need indeed indeed as the hiring
platform where you can attract interview
and hire all in one place don't spend
hours on multiple job sites looking for
candidates with the right skills you can
do it all with indeed but in Top Talent
fast with indeed Suite of powerful
hiring tools like indeed instant match
assessments and virtual interviews you
hate waiting indeed you as data shows
over 80 percent of indeed employers find
quality candidates whose resume on
indeed matches their job description the
moment they sponsor a job it can be very
intimidating Millie you're looking for
someone you've got all these websites
out when it's confused yeah you don't
know where to go indeed put it all in
one place it saves you time you can
message schedule and interview top
talent all in one spot join over three
million businesses worldwide using
indeed to hire great talent faster now
indeed knows that when you're growing
your business you have to make every
dollar count that's why when you sponsor
a job you only pay for Quality
applications from resumes in their
database matching your job description
visit indeed.com onion to start hiring
now just go to indeed.com
indeed.com onion terms and condition
supply cost per application pricing not
available for everyone need to hire you
need indeed can we talk about
notifications for a second now does
anybody ever leave those sounds on
anymore
well except that came oh yeah that's
another sale on Shopify the all-in-one
Commerce platform to start run and grow
your business Shopify makes it simple to
sell to anyone from anywhere whether
your thing is vintage teas or recipes
for ghee start selling with Shopify
enjoy the platform simplifying Commerce
for millions of your favorite businesses
worldwide with Shopify you'll create an
online store in your Vibe discover new
customers and grow the followers that
keep them coming back Shopify has all
the sales channels sorted so your
businesses keep growing from an
in-person POS system to an all-in-one
e-commerce platform even across social
media platforms like Tick Tock Facebook
and Instagram and thanks to the 24 7
support and Free Library is full of
educational content Shopify has got you
every step of the way it's how every
minute new sellers around the world make
their first sale with Shopify and you
will too it's fantastic Shopify as you
know my wife uses it for his business
now t-shirts setting up easy easy looks
brilliant works great Shopify makes
selling simple so you can put yourself
and your ideas out there whether your
thing is making ebooks or earrings
Shopify meets your success possible
sign up for a free trial at shopify.com
onion all lowercase go to shopify.com
onion to start selling online today
shopify.com
now what about we do go off at tangents
but let's go back a little bit right
what what about the day when after all
these auditions your agent coaching say
you got it what happened that day do you
remember yeah because I was at work
um I was at my office job so the way it
worked was I got a call from my agent
saying that Ryan ROM so the writer
director and producer wanted to talk to
me and in my mind I was like great it's
going to be like one of those pats on
the back like great job kid maybe next
time
um
but they wanted to see me like in person
so I was like okay I'm gonna go during
my lunch break from my office job and I
went to this casting office
um
and I sat there and I remember sitting I
remember they had all these coffee book
like coffee table books on the table
I never read those but of course that
day I was like I'm so busy I'm so
casually looking at this book like I
don't care about anything that's about
to happen to me
um and I remember Ryan walking in and
being like Oh Kelly hi and I was like oh
just reading this give me a moment
please yeah yeah well exactly
um and then we went into the casting
room and he basically there was like a
little back and forth of talking because
we hadn't talked and I think there was
like a month in between every audition
because they were looking for people
everywhere
um
and then he said that he wanted to offer
me
the role and I remember okay this is the
moment I feel like I remember as a child
like you dream about what it would be
when you when you were to receive the
thing that you think is going to
complete your life and I remember
thinking like oh there's gonna be like
celebration and screaming and like just
like Euphoria and I remember my first
feeling just being like straight out
fear like I was so terrified and I
didn't respond for a very long time like
I just sat there like Frozen and then I
just remember there was silence for
maybe what felt like an eternity was
probably like a minute and he goes
so do you want this
[Laughter]
I've never been like yeah but I have no
idea what I'm doing and that sort of
feeling that you were talking about Dom
and Philly to like about Rose and about
like the idea that she
was working like in this world from a
place of like I've never done this
before I don't know what I'm doing is a
very
um metaphorical to like the experience I
was having because I very much did not
come from
the world of entertainment at all and it
just was all so new to me
um so yeah it's it's a big Galaxy the
Star Wars Galaxy and I think it's
important sometimes to have characters
that feel a little overwhelmed by where
they are in that Galaxy and that's what
happens I think with rose is she becomes
in a lot of ways the audience because
they think that's what I would be I
would be in that world with explosions
and spaceships and Stormtroopers and be
like oh okay I'm all right I'm all right
and that's you captured that really
beautifully thanks for saying that I
actually want to talk about Lord of the
Rings well we can definitely can we talk
about that yeah yeah I wanna we'll go
backwards and forwards because I want to
keep talking about Star Wars but let's
go backwards and forwards okay let's do
whatever however you wanna what do you
want to ask about Lord of the Rings I
want to ask everything I want well
you're going to New Zealand right you
just told us yes
um that's brilliant and as a as a
straight up kind of Lord of the Rings
fan it's pretty thrilling to go to that
country
I am very excited yes do you think you
might have any time off long weekends or
anything like that I honestly have no
idea what my schedule is going to be
like but I'm there for so long that I'm
hoping that I will have some I'm sure
I'll have weekends
I'll go to hobbiton I'm gonna go to all
the places oh you gotta go so you but
we're not allowed to say what it is that
you're doing in New Zealand but you are
going to be there for quite a long time
five months yeah and you're gonna be in
Auckland yes based in Auckland which is
a great City fantastic City but and and
you're quite close to Hobart and then
not too yeah yeah just head south but
don't go too far so so you'll end up in
the water and then
you will love it it's such a great
country you can actually buy Maps this
is very kind of deep uh geeky culture
but I'm I'm cool with it you can buy
maps of New Zealand but they replace the
modern day City is and what they do is
they show you where the entire
production was filmed around the country
that is so cool so based on you know
where you are you can be like oh well
I'm kind of close to here this weekend
so I could go over here I think we
always say at these kind of conventions
that Billy and I have been lucky to do
and people say I'm going to New Zealand
for the first time what should I
absolutely do we always kind of say try
and get yourself to Queenstown don't we
queenstone yeah I mean we filmed a lot
around there end of the first movie and
all that when Sean Bean tragically dies
trying to save us and but we did all
that stuff and it's beautiful it's all
mountains and we learned how to uh
snowboard down there wow not not Orlando
Bloom of course he was getting
helicoptered to the tops of mountains
and coming down kind of off-piste I
think they call it I think that's what
he called it where is me Dom and Elijah
uh we're having our first lessons and to
go off off a little bit here
off pieced a little bit what that one of
the times I laughed most in my life is
have you ever been skiing and
snowboarding and all I have not oh right
well it's very very embarrassing if you
if you get a little older and you
haven't done it yeah and we were all you
know 30 20s kind of thing and taking our
first lessons and the the the little
lift the little lift thing that takes
you up to the smallest slope you stick a
thing between your legs that's always
moving up and then it kind of drags you
up the hill you know but it's quite hard
to go on yeah that sounds terrifying
it's really difficult so Elijah God
bless him tried about three or four
times and couldn't get on this left it
kept falling off and the last time you
fell off it just held on a thing and get
dragged up on his back all the way up oh
my God
I couldn't stop yeah so definitely go to
Queenstown and do that queenstown's
great because we there's a there's a lot
that goes on that you see in that film
like Billy said obviously Marion Pippin
uh the whole Fellowship breaking up is
Queenstown so you've got Aragon fighting
Lurch the the scary or a car you've got
Frodo and Sam jumping in the boat you've
got us Row in the boats you've got yeah
wow you've got borrow me trying to take
the ring from uh Frodo on that Hill yeah
you've got the big hurricane fight
there's a lot that goes on there and
it's a place called Paradise my only my
only kind of warning with Paradise which
we we got told about on the call shoot
is they have these little sand flies
which are barely noticeable tiny black
little flies that just ruin your skin
don't you no oh really oh I'm so jealous
you're good down there
are you ready for the adventure I'm
ready I'm terrified but ready
um yeah I leave on Sunday okay wow so
fun yeah very cool such a great
definitely go to Wellington as well yeah
you um I know you're sort of East Side
here yeah and and Wellington's kind of
east side it's all oh good to know yeah
um
like outside
the all the coffee shops have like local
artist paintings in and stuff and one
day I'm walking along the street and it
said King Lear and it gave an address
and it wasn't a theater it was someone's
apartment
up to the apartment was it can wear or a
thing yeah I think we I think it was
Leah yeah King weirdo thing and all the
team all the chairs were around this
house and I sat and I watched this wow
and it was directed and starred taika
what yeah what Titi totally forgot about
it until about a year ago and he said to
me you saw my uh King Lear in my
apartment what the hell that's oh that's
what Wellington is like wow only in New
Zealand that type of stuff that's
beautiful isn't it brilliant that's
incredible yeah I'll send you some info
about Wellington especially because we
were based in Wellington and you know
like Chicago to probably Motel right now
and they're probably all cools now I
think motel and Chow are still around oh
we're going to give you a list of things
give me all the things oh it's great
back to Star Wars yeah
there's another adventure so that was
filmed in London right uh yes we uh
Pinewood yeah yeah yeah had you ever
been to England before I had been to
England but very briefly and it like I
um I went on a summer abroad like in
college and I I went to
um Brighton which is in oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah nice little Seaside Town yeah
yeah that's where I was studying for a
summer so I'd been to England before so
all of a sudden then you're going to
Pinewood Studios Super Famous studio and
how long after having the meeting with
the director did that happen
very soon sure it was just like yeah we
want you to do this yeah so actually my
friends that I brought Caitlin who you
met hi Caitlin hi Caitlin
living with at the time and I had to
essentially move out of my apartment I
was also told that I could not tell
anybody like a single soul I couldn't
tell my parents I couldn't tell anyone
um did you say Caitlyn no I had to lie
to her no yeah so I I so she watched me
move out of our apartment which by the
way had Lord of the Rings and Harry
Potter posters all over the apartment
there's actually
um we still have the Lord of the Rings
posters there's three of them the three
of us what the three movie posts the
three movie posters so janzy who's here
and Caitlin I lived with janzi for a
couple years and then I lived with
Caitlyn and those posters were always
around and now we have this thing where
it's like they're kind of always
rotating around between us really that's
cool but yeah so at the time I was
living with Caitlyn and I moved out of
that apartment and moved to and it was
it was very soon after we had that
conversation I had to give my two weeks
notice for my office job I was very
adamant about that wow and then and then
you just said to Caitlin I'm moving out
I said I'm moving to I lived into Europe
no I said I'm moving well I should have
said that I said I'm moving to Canada
for a small Indie movie that I can't
talk about right you lied about the
country why couldn't you just say it you
know when people are bad at lying so
they overcompensate that was definitely
me I'm going to the Moon yeah
this episode is brought to you by better
help
so
sometimes life can get complicated you
know that right I mean it'd be good if
there was some sort of you know a user's
manual that you could flip through the
pages and think oh I'm feeling a bit
down today what am I supposed to do
about that I didn't sleep well last
night I'm worried about this new job but
it doesn't unfortunately life doesn't
come with a user manual so that it's not
working for you it's normal that you
feel stuck and it's nice sometimes to
have someone to talk to of course
friends and family can do that for you
yes you're fantastic for that but every
so often you might need a professional
whether you're dealing with a trauma or
maybe you need a little bit of a
conversation with someone about some
self-empowerment or maybe some coping
skills you need better help
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available a hundred
percent online plus it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with the therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime it couldn't be simpler
no waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapists learn
more and save 10 of your first month at
betterhelp.com onion that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash onion
Star Wars is a very overwhelming
experience I mean for me it was it was
the most overwhelming experience oh for
sure I've never had that horrible day on
set remember you talked about it yeah
the only horrible truly horrible day
I've ever had on set was unfortunately
on Star Wars and I spent more time with
Kelly Marie and Billy than anyone else
on the set but on this particular day
which was my first day oh I was doing a
scene with John Daisy Anthony Daniels
Jonas R2D2
and it's a it's a trip were you in that
scene I think maybe I feel like I was
always around when you think you're
around pressing buttons yeah exactly and
there's a camera on a crane 200 feet
away something like that and I've got
this monologue and JJ just said
obviously just wait for the camera to
rest it's gonna go it's gonna wipe past
a couple of creatures and aliens and
droids and then it's gonna settle in
between C3PO and and Chewbacca's
shoulders and then you're gonna start
and I was like right okay hahaha
I've told you this line right yeah they
didn't make it into the film JJ JJ
emailed me a few months later and he
said we're not using that scene we're
gonna have Daisy do the thing instead
and I was like thank God because that
was my least favorite dancer but I had
to say and it's weird because I can
remember it now and I couldn't remember
it on the day you can't get to
you can't get to hexago you need a super
luminite lodestone star composer tune to
hyperspace vectors
so the camera's coming from like you
know 60 feet 50 feet 40 feet 30 feet and
it's resting I'm like okay got it got it
and I'm and I'm thinking okay I've got
the line and I go you can't get to
hexagonal
x-ray with this and judge would be like
no reset and the reset would take like
four or five minutes yeah because it's
droids going backwards and creatures
going backwards and we did this like
three or four times it's fine I'm
starting to this horrible moment as well
to start to feel this little beads of
sweat going down your head Oscar Oscar's
in the scene me lovely lovely Oscar
Oscar put his arm around me he's like
hey fine don't worry about because
Austin's been doing it for years on the
Star Wars set he knows that you're
having a bit of a moment he's like it's
fine we'll do it we'll get it and I was
like yeah yeah we'll get it tried it
again didn't get it and then this awful
moment where JJ who I've known for 20
years came over to me and he went I can
always tell when JJ's getting a little
you know hooked and JJ came over he went
it's it is fine it's fine
you do need to get it now
yeah I will I will I'll get it but JJ's
basically just saying you know this is a
huge money set and if you don't get this
in the next 15 to 20 minutes we have to
move on because we've got an afternoon
of scenes to do and it's costing us
hundreds of thousands of dollars so he
came over and just kind of went fine
and I was like okay I'll get it I'll get
it sweat rolling down my back was I just
guys like taking off their Wookie
I've never had a day like that
terrifying and then it was done and we
did and we did the scene and I got
through it but I was not happy about
what what I did necessarily and I went
over to Daisy and John and ask her and I
was like oh God I'm sorry guys that was
like an awful day for me and they were
like nah it's fine and they went over to
JJ and I said the same thing I was like
my bad man you know I I think it took
eight or nine takes instead of two or
three and JoJo's like it's fine it's
great we'll we'll figure it out you know
if there's a moment where it doesn't
look great we've got a shot of Daisy and
John and Oscar and Kelly Marie over
there and all these people I was like
okay and then months later he called me
and he went we've actually given that
narrative piece the the super illuminite
lodestone star Compass piece to Daisy
and I was like thank God because I would
have been mortified watching me that's a
lot of words and it is like and I was
jet lagged and it's Star Wars yeah there
is something
something so overwhelming about being in
that space and seeing these characters
that people have loved for so long
there's something terrible that we've
all loved you yeah would you have fun
before you I'm gonna be honest I was not
I did not grow up in Star Wars I grew up
had you seen it Lord of the Rings
have you seen Star Wars filming
um no no wow
wow wow so it probably didn't have that
same which actually helped me in the
auditions that I didn't have this sort
of like reverence for it and I think it
actually helped me to create a character
that
didn't for me like I felt like I was
totally clean slating it it was like I
wasn't trying to be like anyone else
yeah yeah I would agree with that
slightly out of the normal kind of ideas
of the trophy characters in Star Wars
you're in your own lane for sure yeah I
was doing a check off play once and
there was a young ass is it a seagull
darling no it wasn't darling it was um
it was the cherries
it's a young actor in it and he he said
to the director I've never seen any
Chekhov I better go and watch something
and the director said no don't
because then you'll bring something new
if you what then you're just doing The
Chariot so then you do the one that
you've seen before so I think that I
think that's really important but smart
of the director my favorite day on set
since we're talking about the worst one
it'd be nice to have one that was great
which I wish I shared with you Kelly
Marie and Billy and a few other people
was do you remember when on that massive
set that was kind of the invasion at the
end and they they did a huge reset
because he had Stormtroopers on wires
and explosions remember that yeah so
that that moment the reset on that was
probably half an hour and JJ's on the
mic like this and he said guys it's
going to be half an hour but we'd really
prefer it if you stayed on set because
if you leave it's going to take us an
hour to get everyone back and you're
gonna go eat and you're gonna go do this
thing so we're like yeah we'll stay they
played Intergalactic by the Beastie Boys
and we all at a dance party for half an
hour it was really fun Stormtroopers and
the resistance all dancing so good did
you have fun in London I really did good
I love London I'm a big theater fan so
um being able to just like live in
London and go see theater like you're
going to see a movie like I would just
go by myself and be like one ticket
please and I just saw so many shows uh
that's great yeah big big where were you
based where did they put you um
uh what part of town I was live I I kind
of kind of drawn to a bunch of different
places
but I really like the east side of
them so I was in dalston for part of it
right yeah yeah
um we stayed in the Langan for a while
yeah we were there for a really long
time I love that hotel a lot yeah and
then just go in and watch and see it
brilliant yeah innocent stick in your
mind theater wise that you saw oh my
goodness
um you know what I saw that's actually
coming to La it's coming to the Geffen
but I saw the inheritance when it was in
oh did you London yeah and it blew my
mind oh great we'll go see it yeah it's
coming into Geffen like really soon
um since let's go back let's go back to
a Lord of the Rings since you grew up
quote unquote on on Lord of the Rings
yes
when how old were you when that first
film came out do you know the first
movie come out in 2001 2001 yeah I was
in sixth grade so how old's sixth grade
I don't do grades eleven twelve did you
go see at the cinema yeah with your
family with your friends oh my my
parents love my parents they're just not
into movies they hate Star Wars they
hate sci-fi they hate fantasy they just
so I went with my friends
and how come you as an 11 year old knew
about Lord of the Rings had you read the
book did you read it at school I read
The Hobbit I had a seventh grade teacher
um actually
I don't remember what I had a teacher
who was like obsessed with J.R Tolkien
and just like had us now that I look
back I'm like was he able to just create
his own curriculum because I think he
did we read The Hobbit and we like had
to make our own board games of like The
Hobbit it was incredible it was great uh
hi Mr Farr if you're listening hi Mr
Ferry
yeah we had Stephen Colbert on our show
who we I don't think either one of us
were aware of how much of a of a Tolkien
Fanny is especially of the books I mean
he he has high reverence for the books
Stephen subscribes to a podcast in which
every week they read one single sentence
from Lord of the Rings and then they
break it down over the course of an hour
I was like how long is that podcast yeah
he's you read some of the book every day
every day you go back and read something
he's a nice guy he's so lovely he's my
favorite I like a modern Dome actually
yeah and I like Dom quite a lot no he
does he's a very lovely wholesome men
Stephen Colbert smart so so tell us
about that funny yeah very funny tell us
about that that Cinema experience did
had you read reviews or previews did you
go in kind of blind I didn't even know
that reviews were a thing until I
started working in entertainment like I
really knew you were getting them really
yeah but I was like oh I should be aware
of what people are writing about me no
yeah I um went in fully blind and I
became very obsessed very quickly like I
I think it was
you know I grew up on Disney movies and
sort of like had a love for I feel like
animated Disney movies are full of magic
and like some sort of
um pixie dust yeah pixie dust
um but Lord of the Rings and Harry
Potter were like two of the very big
very big life-changing things in my in
my childhood absolutely yeah so it's
very cool to be here did you did you
have a favorite Hub
what are you doing I'm just asking
questions that's what you're doing
podcasts but we've we've been friends
for a long time
I would guess from her email which we
wouldn't say what it is I would guess
it's maybe not one of us
Sean Aston is an extremely uh popular
um man Hobbit well man and hobby we I'm
obsessed with the Beatles both
billionaire are obsessed with the
Beatles on these conventions that we've
been doing we've been doing little
homages to Beatles albums and I very
quickly selected Sean to be Ringo
because Ringo was the most popular Beal
in the United States he got more fan
mail more like than anyone else more
adorable because at these conventions
Sean always has the longest line and
he's the most popular I think he's well
loved yeah because that's some ways Sam
is so hot
very wholesome it doesn't do as much for
the fellowship as Pippin does but well
you know I would say hard worker he's a
hard worker I don't know if you remember
the movies but Mary Mary stabs the witch
King which is a real Warrior Hobbit
moment but not to death you just knock
about with Gandalf for a Trilogy you
just you stubborn in the knee I think
yeah I give him him right in the knee so
that he so that he drops to the level
for earwin to stab otherwise she
wouldn't have been able to reach his
head meanwhile you're just that kind of
Knob Ed friend that hangs out with a
wizard that is like okay and smokes
eight weeks a lot of pipe but shouldn't
you have stabbed them maybe in the liver
or something I don't know you could
reach I mean maybe if I jumped yeah okay
someone had mentioned this thing the
other day about the idea that if if
Frodo were to attach the ring maybe tie
it in a lovely kind of ribbon around a
mouse and then keep the mouse in his
pocket surely the mouse would take on
board all of the heavy pain of the ring
and him and Sam could just stroll along
for a couple of years and just drop the
mouse and I was like that is profound
because when Sam picks up Frodo yeah he
doesn't take off does he so Mr trick
there Mr wouldn't you end up with like a
Golem Mouse oh yeah eating fish and all
that yeah you wouldn't want to see that
would you no you would definitely
wouldn't want to see them and then you
need to drop a mouse into your volcano
yeah which is bad luck in a lot of
countries is that true yeah yeah tedious
bad luck
peeling The Onion
um well what else we've got some
questions here which we could all do
should we should we jump into a question
we could do a riddle let's do one riddle
are you good at riddles
Terrible's in the dark very excited
all right well let's try one do we know
the answer
I know I'm I'm meditating right now this
is from Adam C in Saint Louis is it
Saint Louis or St Louis well it depends
if you're singing it or saying it oh
what would you say calamari
I think you're right I think if you say
I don't know
[Music]
well I think you said
what would John say would you say St
Louis or St Louis is this the riddle
I keep forgetting I have to press a
button today once I came out here I
started saying St Louis more but when I
was in Chicago I'd say St Louis so say
you lived in St Louis what would you say
my friend my best friends is from St
Louis and I think he does say St Louis
right well we'll go with that and if
they see see uh my hand was the United
States of America there calamari this
being
um
California
New York got it and Florida got it where
is Saint Louis Saint Louis
she's good in the geography it's there
right that right in the very Medical
Center is that right John she's bang on
she's absolutely I did win the geography
van third grade did you really yeah I
did did you win Miss Bale and B as well
no I didn't what was it a geography quiz
like Capital Cities and stuff like that
yeah really yeah brilliant Dom knows all
the capital cities of all this world do
you no well I am pretty good on Capital
Cities I'm animals I'm good Capital
Cities I'm not that good Jakarta
okay wait here's a little tip Kelly
Marie this is actually kind of a
Scottish tip but I'm gonna do it on
behalf of Billy thank you John if you
because you know maybe you will be in
Britain sometime soon if you do manage
to get yourself to Scotland it's
important to pronounce this city
Edinburgh and not as a lot of people in
the United States say which is Edinburgh
that will make you stand out as if not
knowing what you're talking about it's
Edinburgh Edinburgh there you go wow
Middlesbrough Peterborough as soon as an
American person says borrow everyone's
like you don't know
all right we're moving on you can take
that in New Zealand as well I don't know
if it's any use I'll just keep saying it
in New Zealand let's see if uh lots of
Scots people are there actually lots of
Scottish people emigrated to New Zealand
there's a great city right down the
bottom of New Zealand called
help me Don well is it Christchurch no
it's further south and it has a castle
it's only city with a castle Dunedin
Dunedin well done done tremendous
is like a little Scotland all the cities
are Scottish names from Edinburgh and
there it's got a castle it was a
Scottish guy who went there and uh you
should go there as well it's a brilliant
it is like a mini Scotland rains a lot
everyone's Miserable as something else
that's something else you can fly down
there in a weekend from yeah is it a
very
from north to south if you drive him
because the roads you know they keep the
countryside pretty
um legit the drive from the top of the
South Island to the bottom is a good day
right or two but you can fly down there
in an hour I'm so excited for you I wish
I was good That's so exciting hey guys
should we get to this riddle yeah
right we've got two riddles here but
I'll do the first one from Adam C in St
Louis it goes like this with thieves I
consort with the vilest in short I am
quite at my ease in depravity yet all
divines use me and savants cannot lose
me for I am the center of gravity
what am I my God Dominic if you don't
know maybe that could you give us that
again all right we'll we'll slow it down
a little bit
with thieves I can sort
with the vilest in short the violence I
am quite at my ease in depravity yet all
divines use me to feigns gods and stuff
and savants cannot lose me for I am the
center of gravity what am I well this
what is it let's start from the end John
lovely stop start from the back and go
towards the beginning the center of
gravity is
why is the center wait
the sun is the center wait I've got it
I've got it what is it I've got it what
is it what is the center of gravity it's
the letter v
so read the rest of it wait no no it is
with thieves I can sort there's a v in
thieves with the vile list in short
starts with a V I am quite at ease in
depravity has a v in it oh my god get
all divines use me and savants cannot
lose me for I am the center of gravity
that was the fastest I've ever seen
unbelievable real answer to my life hey
wow wow we figured that out I'm fully
impressed right I am very impressed
because he's normally stupid
that was amazing
would you want to read out a question
and then we'll jump into some tasty
business what oh yeah what question
would we have I don't know
we've got one about nicknames do you and
your pals have nicknames for each other
Kelly Marie
uh I don't think so we could talk about
the fact that I walked around calling
you kellyanne for a week uh
so on set right for like the first week
or so I just thought Kelly and Tran it
just rolls off the top it's quite good
Kelly and Tran she's an actress Kelly
and Tran I was like oh yeah it's kind of
a cool funky name so for the first week
you know like I said spend a lot of time
with Kelly Marie and Billy just chatting
chatting chatting and saying all right
see you later kellyanne see you later
Kelly and I'm gonna get a cup of tea
Kelly and then I came on set and at one
point
both JJ and all the other casts kept
mentioning kellyanne's name and then
looking at me so they'd be like are you
good there kellyanne
don't look at me and I was like what
what what's going on here and then
eventually Kelly Murray had to be late
my name is actually Kelly Marie you've
been calling me but it's just there's
something so
accuracy about that name kellyanne
kellyanne Tran Kelly Anthony Kelly Marie
were you where did is that family why
did you get called Kelly Marie yeah so
Maria's actually I have two sisters and
we all have a middle name Marie oh
really yeah is it what is that in honor
of like a a family member or something
um my mom was really religious so it's
like yeah yeah and then all three of us
have names that start with k
um my mom and dad made this deal when
they were like about to have children
that if it was a girl it would start
with the K because my mom's name starts
at the K my dad's name starts with an l
so he always we had no L's because there
were no boys in her face
did they tell you what you might have
been if you were a boy were you going to
be like a Lionel actually I was gonna be
either Louis or Louis depending on how
you pronounce that word and if you're
singing it bring it back yeah exactly
brilliant Kelly Marie was also a pop
star in in the 80s and really Britain it
was just Kelly Marie so I was hoping
that maybe you'd be named after her yeah
Wonder yeah
[Music]
foreign
this podcast has got very surreal I love
it I love it if John could bring that up
just know I would love him for it Kelly
Marie
Gammon love I'm in love I'm in love
Kayla Marie from the 1980s John will
find it but one uh Billy why don't you
ask this question from Rob Sutcliffe
right ready Manchester in England where
are you from I might actually ask the
one from currency in Orlando I'll put
Paul Rob now but that's all right we'll
do both go on in so Colin C in Orlando
because I thought this might be good for
uh Kelly Marie because
um she likes to Lord of the Rings films
from sixth grade oh this would be a
great one no Kayla Marie
Who Would You cast if Elijah Sean John
and belly were not cast as the four
Hobbits and you can cast it from anybody
through history actors are known actors
that's messed up who would you cast as
the as the four Hobbits well first I'll
say it was perfectly cast and I wouldn't
want to change anything
why thank you thank you and John that's
a wrap I would have switched out Pippin
I think you McGregor I think McGregor
would have been a great Pippin he would
he's a sexy person yeah I bet you get
more close-ups
Who Would You cast who would you choose
right here we go
soften it no it's easy
for
let's let's let's pick one pick Frodo
Baggins
Jimmy Durante who's that well you've got
your look him up it's some ways
guarantee
do you know a friend of mine was
actually up for some ways gamji in
Scotland I won't mention his name but a
wonderful actor and I think it was down
to the last two but I won't mention ham
has been uh was the process are you
talking about yeah oh it's real it was
the your process also like it wasn't
what it was super fast Billy was the
first person casting the film wait what
do you mean well we at mine was pretty
long
I think they were having difficulty with
Mary well of course these are very
complicated character and he's not
who has got that kind of yeah he's
actually in a second one that depth of
character but yet this sexual tension
yeah yeah that energy that kind of raw
physical masculine sexuality where you
could take this character right through
to the end I've ruined my script there I
got so much excited when he stabs a guy
in the knee when he should have got him
in the river it's too small Billy you
still went for the lover yeah
that could have been your moment yeah I
could have stolen that from Miranda
actually I've been brilliant but you're
going yours is very fast you're casting
how many additions so uh on tape with
the casting director that tape was sent
to New Zealand to yeah and then like
with your Star Wars I think they were
looking all over the world so Then Pete
went to Los Angeles New York Sydney
London I met him in London with a friend
Walsh we spent about an hour doing
scenes and then basically a week after
that I got a phone call offered me the
bar they're all sat around going to Pete
and friend what about this guy what
about this guy what about this game it's
going uh he's going now we need an idiot
we need an actual like a legitimate
idiot someone's whose brain has started
to Apple over the last few years can you
think of anyone and Pete's like you know
what I've seen it say give
[Applause]
[Laughter]
mine was longer yeah mine was longer um
I had two auditions with the Hubbards
both on tape and then you auditioned
together like no no no no separate what
yeah of course you didn't meet until you
were to meet until New Zealander he was
working he was filming in France in the
show in France so I was playing a guy
who gets his head all shaven off at the
end of the show in France so I went into
audition for Lord of the Rings after
being punched on the tube on the
Underground in London because someone
must have thought it was a skinhead or
maybe just wanted to punch me anyway so
I didn't have a black guy but I had kind
of a yellow eye you know when it goes
kind of yellowy purple skinhead and I'm
auditioning for a generic Hobbit roll
which was when Gandalf knocks on the
door and says to Frodo you know be
careful with that ring type thing you
keep it secreted keep it safe did that
twice
and on the second time that I did it
always is good you're fine
I'm so excited on the second time that I
did it they were getting all the tape
kind of ready and John Hubbard To Go
Runs The Hobbit casting agency said
could you just wait for 10 15 minutes
just to make sure that the tape is fine
and we've recorded it we need to rewind
it and make sure it's all entire I said
yeah fine and he said if you wait
another five or ten minutes we're
expecting David Bowie to audition shut
and I was like watch and eventually yep
shut up so I sat like you with the
coffee table but I sat there with a huge
coffee table books
seven pizza and every time the door
opened I was like here he comes here
comes the Thin White Duke and eventually
eventually he walked in and just kind of
went hello and I went hello David Bowie
and then he went in and I was like yes
and then are you kidding me we hold
he auditioned I think for elrond I think
right the Hugo Weaver I am shaking yeah
I think for the longest time people
thought that you auditioned for Gandalf
but I don't think it was Gandalf I think
it was elrond yeah it'd be an elf
wouldn't it be now but he was wearing
like a gun metal suit kind of shiny
looking suit perfect hair came in
obviously didn't know me from a hole in
the wall but just kind of said hello and
for me for the next 20 years of my life
that counted as meeting David Bowie so
I'd be like I met David Bowie people
like he walked through a room that you
were sat in it doesn't really count wow
many years later Elijah and I went to a
concert after Rings came out and I
actually did meet him then and I told
him that story yeah yeah did you
remember yeah well he didn't remember
that thing but he he obviously
remembered going in and no auditioning
for him have you seen the new
documentary about him no is it good it's
great brilliant wow I'm sorry my heart
is really beautiful yeah no he's a he's
an icon and all that kind of stuff um we
didn't really answer the question did we
who else would play so you've got who
did you say um Dean Martin's gonna be
Jimmy Jimmy Durant is going to be Sam no
idea who that is it's brilliant Frodo
maybe put maybe a young Paul McCartney
lovely lovely Choice yeah I thought so
[Music]
too far a deep Sexual Energy deep Sexual
Energy short short Sexual Energy sure
and also is it
is it Peter Dinklage after a couple of
glasses
after like half a glass of wine I think
you know who I see it as
Olivia
oh Larry yeah dear Larry he'd be good
Larry yeah I think that's great Lauren
still love you yeah I think we've nailed
it incredible hey should we eat the
world because I'd love to die yes Billy
and Dom eat the world
Billy it's another segment of our
favorite part of the show billion dummy
the world and Kelly Marie has brought
what I would deem to be a classic chip
from the United States Kelly Marie it's
over to you yes
um I brought a variety of different
Flamin Hot Cheetos snacks
yes which I grew up on and actually
earlier when you said when you asked if
my friends have any nicknames for me my
friend Yancey out there calls me
sometimes talk talk which stands for
Thug of Cheetos oh wow because I'm a
very big Cheeto fan so this was kind of
your little happy treat when you were a
kid yeah it was this is something that
your parents were okay with you eating
because probably not that good for you
it's so not good for you yeah my sisters
and I would fight over who got to eat
the crumbs in the bag
sometimes my dog will do that he'll
it'll go it will go after a bee or
something and then I can see in his eyes
when he imagined what that bee would be
like in his mouth and he goes
and that's what I felt like with the the
sand do you not like spicy I don't I
don't mind it but I'm not gonna throw
this sand from it
this is so good do you like do you eat
Takis you know that those yeah Takis I
do I like to Crunch them in the bottom
and pour that in the mouth as well
hey hey John John have you got any like
little plates anything that we could put
Cheetos on I mean get to a plate right
now thank you John you're the most
wonderful man isn't he just the same
well
do you know what what Johnny Cruz could
play some ways gamji yeah it'd be a
lovely loyal to the end it's just a
wonderful wonderful man and always
walking around with pots and pans on his
back as well uh Kelly Mooney do you want
to choose which bank we start with are
we gonna have all of them we're gonna
have all of them okay then I would start
with the classic
what's coined here an interesting story
for an NPR about Cheetos should we
should we do it right I'll read the
first half page and then I'll leave it
up to you guys to read the second page
so this is a John organizes all this
stuff so this is interesting and John's
Main and John's and then we can see if
as interesting or not here we go in the
late 1980s Richard
Montanez was a janitor at the Frito-Lay
plant could you just put a little few in
the gun stop at the Frito Lay plan in
Rancho Cucamonga to earn some extra
money he would submit ideas to the
factory which was running a sort of
contest for new chip flavors Frito-Lay
has not verified this contest ever
existed by the way Montanez never won
but when stocking chips in a store off
the clock he noticed that the Mexican
spices shelf was next to the snacks
shelf gave him an idea why don't we make
chips spicy so he took cues from the
similarity in shape between and a lot
day I think that's right and a Cheeto
filled a trash bag with cheeseless
Cheetos off the production line took
them home and ultimately invented
flaming hot Cheetos then he called up
Roger Enrico the chief executive at
Frito-Lay at the time to pitch his idea
Enrico ate it
figuratively oh ate it up figuratively
maybe literally two on the spot and the
rest is history it's a great story
it's a great story if this is true
continues John what enter the Los
Angeles Times
inner peace shall we pass this on no no
we're gonna go to the next page
we are minutes so you're saying it might
not be true yes
published just days after the Planet
Money episode aired the times claimed
that Montanez did not in fact invent the
snack and the story is just an urban
legend according to interviews with more
than a dozen former Frito Lays employees
the archival record and free to lay
itself in a statement to the times free
to lay credits Lynn Greenfield a young
NBA and Junior's employee who was tasked
with creating the brand in the late
1980s and Fred Lindsay accomplished
salesman on the south side of Chicago
for pushing the company into a flavor
that category oh sorry into a flavor
category after noticing spicy snacks
from local competitors would just blow
off the shelf now I'll leave this next
page
to the two of you guys can I eat one
please so there was a great story
invented it because he wanted it to be
like a Mexican snack is that right and
he saw that it was next and then the New
York Times came out and said that's not
true that's not true but it continues
hold on wow these are so good they're
very good these would be your favorite
out of the three or do you do you mess
with the other ones as well so I have
not tried these Carolina Reaper ones I
didn't even know they existed so I'm
very excited about those aren't we and
then what's the other one that we've got
Puffs Flamin Hot Puffs
Carolina Reaper a couple of weeks ago
how are you doing I'm still not I'm
still not back to normal really yeah
it's really hot I took some home and
I've been meditating with them in the
morning so take a little slice and for
that 10 minutes that it's hurting just
close your eyes and try and get into it
it gets easier yeah but you said you
were meditating with them I thought you
all sat in a little circle if you could
do that too you're in the jellies yeah
this is tasty right come on someone
needs to do the first half and do the
other half you're doing a Calamity and
I'm eating snacks here we go
ventana's himself only began taking
credit for inventing Flamin Hot Cheetos
during paid speaking engagements in the
2000s
his claims went viral when the media
promoted his feel-good rags to Rich's
tale it all went unchecked by Frito-Lay
for several years as most of the
executives involved in developing the
Flamin Hot brand had already retired
until
2018.
that's when Greenfield heard Martin as a
story and contacted corporate an
internal investigation was launched that
resulted in no evidence of Montana's
claims I'm doing a terrible job
if that story existed believe me we
would have heard about it Ken lucasca
who worked as a product manager for the
core Cheetos brand when Flamin Hots were
rolling out nationally told the times
this guy should run for office if he's
that good at fooling everyone oh oh what
a quote to give the time wow the times
further notes that Enrico the CEO
Montana's claims he pitched his creation
to didn't even take over the Frito-Lay
brand until early 1991 which is several
months after Flamin Hot Cheetos were
already in test markets like Chicago
Houston and Detroit oh but here the
story takes a turn again in the form of
Al Kerry and I will pass it over to you
bills bring us home
hold on you don't even know where you
are dude well I was listening I wasn't I
wasn't reading stick your finger nearby
you're right yeah right about there okay
yeah I'm actually enjoying these are
very few yeah they're lovely actually
yeah oh I'm so glad
Kiri was the vision president of
Frito-Lay West in 1992 when he says he
first met Montanez who pitched him ideas
targeted at the Latino Market Kiri has
consistently towed the line in claiming
that Montana's invented Flamin Hots and
also that they existed before
one time years so
he says I'm sure if you went back into
Frito-Lay history okay there's probably
something in 1990 there was a test
marker on a spicy product okay did we
yeah
according to the times I'll be surprised
if it was the same ingredient but it
could have been a guess
and his part has doubled down on his
story wow well he did not participate in
the early times investigation he spoke
with variety
saying all I can tell you is what I did
all I have is my history what I did in
my kitchen what a lovely quote
in an opinion column published today in
the times Gustavo
who wrote about Montana's story back in
a 2012 book offered his take on the
situation Gustavo said I understand why
people are rallying behind Montana's the
truth hurts for one and their
frustration over Sam Deen's article
isn't so much about Montana's rather
than a microcosm of two big issues that
continue to play Mexicans in the United
States historical Erasure and the
continued yearning for Heroes that white
America can also Embrace wow will we
ever have the full story uh the full
truth of the story probably not but
honestly it's the myth we enjoy more
anyway wow no one really knows who
invented the flame in hot cheetah if
anyone ever asked me Dom I will say it
was Montana yes I like that story me too
that he took his history and his culture
and he said I'm going to make something
and I like that so I'm going with that
story I like that too it's a nice story
hey should we open another bag because I
like the ogs right I'm loving them now
all right we're gonna eat Puffs yes so
these they're just puffy this is how I
feel about them I'm excited for you to
try them
um different texture okay not as crunchy
a lot more air yes but also because of
the air I think the density of the well
I really love these um the density of
the crowded is is different and
therefore the spice is like at a higher
rate oh nice so bees feel more spicy
than me and would you see better or not
as good as the original I would say
that I enjoy the crunchy texture but
every once in a while it's like a little
change you know it's like well I'll have
some of those okay so you may choose
this over the original sometimes yeah
now the look of it is like a darker
what's it done it's like a dark what's
it yeah we have we have do you know
what's it's out of Britain yeah William
will you be mother I love her watch that
don't I like it what's it
yeah that's good oh they're Whoppers
actually yeah they're absolute crackers
Kelly Marie would you pair these with
anything do do you dip these in anything
or do they go with a soda or anything
like that so I don't dip these I also
think they're hard to do with soda just
because of how spicy they are it just
sort of I don't know makes it taste
weird the soda I guess
um do you like these
how do you feel about the texture
different right you're right they're
spicier because the space is all over
the top of them right yeah but I like
the texture because it's more like a
what's it I like um so I might like
these better oh however you've been
eating these for what 20 years or so
yeah
um very long time I get the feeling
correct me if I'm wrong but I get the
feeling that they could
create quite a funk in your mouth
in your mouth if you if you went about
your day and didn't brush your teeth the
next four or five hours and then tried
to oh yeah they're not good for you I
used to read articles about how people
got sent to the hospital from eating too
many like this is an actual thing there
was like some how many would you need to
eat oh you have to eat a lot
I mean I yeah I have to give myself
limits I really really like those chips
tackies
then I went online to read about if
they're good and or bad for you and
they're not that good and then I stopped
hating them but I really like them I
like these better yeah I think I still
prefer the OG ones but these are tasty
right let's go crazy let's go Carolina
Reaper so these are the ones I will
honestly say I've never tried didn't
even know they existed John must John
said I don't know if he was kidding but
he said he went to 30 Ralphs so well
it's a lot of Ralphs yeah that is a lot
around Billy are you gonna get a
flashback because the last time you had
a Carolina Reaper you got hot hiccups
and they look very painful I got hot
hiccups and then after that I got a
cramp like you wouldn't believe a cramp
yeah and my stomach oh no the guy who
made the Carolina Reaper said that you
might get that and then I thought uh I
don't think I will but I did
you've got siblings right I've got two
sisters
one older one younger do you do your
sisters enjoy these oh yeah this is like
a big every time my sisters were
actually here this weekend because I'm
leaving for five months and we just ate
you know what I'll show you a picture we
have so many bags of chips
and all we did was watch Lord of the
Rings and chips
what a fun weekend incredible look I
will do that
a lot of chips right yeah the picture is
uh Kelly Marie with her two sisters and
honestly 20 bags of chips okay
[Applause]
all right nowhere near as hot as an
actual Carolina Reaper and a strange
flavor oh it's like a barbecue or the
it's not I don't like that at all no
I don't know if you've ever had a
Carolina Reaper but it doesn't taste
like that no no no it's a it's a strange
taste of Carolina Reaper because
obviously there's a flavor but the
overwhelming feeling of eating a
Carolina Reaper is this body sensation
it's like the flavor in The Taste goes
out the window doesn't it it's like your
whole body starts to have a reaction to
it yeah and that is the that is the
feeling of eating it you just start
sweating immediately or um
I know I actually sweat
I got the hiccups really bad I got hot
teeth my all my teeth felt like they
were like roasting hot to touch which
they obviously weren't
um hot mouth hot throat everything kind
of hot and did you have just a tiny bite
of it yeah I bet down to the uh seeds no
I don't think you did have the seeds I
had the seeds you know that's the
hottest part
he just he just sits in a circle and
meditates meditates with the seeds
occasionally they'll go a yoga class
together it claimed that you had the
seeds but when I looked at the basket he
took there was no evidence that he took
this I don't think he didn't
um hey I don't like them yeah these
Reaper ones are too sweet I don't
definitely not
um as good as the other two what should
we give him some skirts Kelly we like to
give
um these things scores in three
different categories William goes over
to you
as taste or flavor after that we're
going to do Aesthetics how does it look
and the third one is how useful are they
oh useful taste now are we doing bills
are we doing like an overall flaming hot
Cheetos thing I think we do you kind of
pick your favorite you don't have to say
which one it is but you give the scores
on that one lovely taste I think it's
going to be high for killing me yeah
really oh it's going to be high I'm
going to get some more of the OG ones
ready
and it's out of 10.
um it's out of there ten ten and um and
you can use decimals if you feel like
it's not a four or a five it's a 4.6
you're allowed to do that taste ten
wow
would you would you say it's your
all-time favorite snack absolutely wow
so you're a Savory person not a sweet
person necessarily oh I don't eat
dessert I will after dinner I'll save
room for chips wow you gotta get a
little crunch in every meal you know
yeah it's brilliant yeah don't
flavor for my favorite which is the OG
uh uh Flamin Hot Cheeto um it's great I
like a Hot Chip I'm giving it an eight
that's good yeah I think the flavor it's
much better than I thought they were I
didn't think I like them but I do like
them so I'll give it uh
I'll give that an eat as well done
lovely wow how does it look to you it
looks crazy really it looks okay I I
will say it's obviously very nostalgic
for me because I grew up eating them but
if we're looking at these from a place
of like if I saw this just randomly in
the world I think I'd be like that does
not look like food yep does not look
healthy no it doesn't look like food
looks full of chemicals absolutely and I
would guess little kids probably get
their mouths all stained with it and the
fingers and stuff like that and the
tongue maybe so I usually eat these with
chopsticks
oh do you really to keep yourself yeah
so you don't have the red fingers Fancy
Pants
I'm sorry I didn't bring any chopsticks
today no it's all right I kind of like
the look it's in a it's in a unique
original look looks as if they're on
fire I don't know
it's a seven to me I'm giving it a seven
um did you give her a score no no all
right no yeah I'll go then well yeah I'm
going to go the original it's a funny
shape as it works I like the color
though it does look like it's on fire
um I'm gonna give the
uh 7.5 lovely wow I mean you might think
that you could you could think that the
factory making these these would be all
the offshoots that didn't quite work
yeah they're like no it's a weird shape
but they've actually embraced the fact
that the shape is peculiar you know what
I actually now that I'm looking at the
original I think the Puffs are actually
prettier to look at yeah I think I'd
give the puffs
a nine oh wow yeah I know and the
original I'd probably give it an eight
and what do you think's most attractive
the puff
one here or the original
um
what's it was the English one called we
were just talking about what's it and
what's it oh
because I like the look of a watcher
they're thinner aren't they so they're
basically the same but a more orange
well they're not cheesy what's this
whereas these are more kind of hot yeah
I like to watch a bit better yeah no
last one Gala Marie
how useful are they how useful is it
Gallery sellers on this
they're not useful at all they're in
your you run some friends have arrived
at your apartment yeah your franchise
right yeah yeah unannounced oh we're
hungry they say but not just for chips
and you and you go into your cupboard
and there's not much there and you get
in your fridge you've got a packet of
them
you've got some self-raising flour a
couple eggs a half pound of milk
and what was the same with you no hold
on there's always eggs and flour
some uh bits of chocolate just left over
from like a bar and is it useful is
there something you can do with it yeah
I mean I would definitely feed them to
my friends just as they are just as they
are can we do anything else I mean you
can't really you can't really do
anything
so people right
there's now
um hot Cheeto mac and cheese which is
actually very good you can have make a
mac and cheese and Crush like crunchy
Hot Cheetos on top
yeah that's nice I mean people are like
Kelly Marie you are a magician in the
kitchen yeah could you use that
flavoring
and throw it around into popcorn and now
you've got flaming hot Cheetos popcorn
yeah actually they do make flaming hot
Cheetos popcorn it's very good so
there's a few things I feel like you can
scatter it on top of things
maybe on a a chicken
on a chicken a chicken breast for
instance that's a big swing that's a big
if it's going in the oven anyway you
know we've got some mozzarella on there
I have seen Flamin Hot Cheeto like
chicken
um like chicken fingers like fried
chicken fingers and they put I haven't
tried those yet so I can't say so I
think there may be more useful than you
would think it's portable I always think
can you take it to a football match and
give out to the players at half time you
absolutely can you can be like hey guys
you're feeling a little depleted have a
few apples and flaming hot Cheetos
um
kids love them right kids love them kids
love them car trips road driving no I
think we're pushing up there yeah I'm
sitting there quick can I get that score
please love that I'm going to give it a
9.2 for you wow I think they're useful
wow
it's one of them things that if you had
it in your cupboard at home and someone
arrived on a note she'd be like I don't
really have anything but I do have some
flaming hot Cheetos for you so I'm going
to say the same I'm gonna give it a 9.2
yeah oh what do you think well I I
really understood the usefulness
um
I love these yeah you do I want to give
it a chance
what the heck so the scores from
calamari there was a nine nine ten ten
nine ten oh was it ten well the flavor
was ten wow
amazing
[Music]
as we have mentioned today on the
Friendship onion uh Kelly Marie here
whose name came from well just lesson
back and you'll know but I thought maybe
she was named after the 80s pop
sensation Kelly Marie whose song we have
now on is it funky for you let's have a
listen to Kelly Marie
there we go
just take you back to your nightclub in
dares
[Music]
I could just see you on the dance floor
in a disco in the 80s bills
yeah
feels like I'm in Love no come on we
scored this
and quite a difficult way Kayla Marie
yeah you might not like this we scored
this and how funky is it for you on a
score range of not very funky ROMs to as
funky as you can get Prince
so you can score anything in between
like say for instance I would score that
as
Earth winds and fire oh I was very close
to what I was gonna say I was gonna say
Boney M a bony M level of funk bunium
another question
[Music]
what's the most famous trailer
oh brown girl in the ring
and
um
something else that they did there's a
lot of stuff Bonnie M they were very
good very kind of slightly 70s Cosmic
Funk hang on here's John very
interesting fact uh oh this was written
for Elvis Presley originally the pelvis
yes but unfortunately when he died they
uh you know obviously couldn't have him
record it yeah be more difficult yeah so
he says the producer Barry Murray was
about to send to Elvis when he got a
phone call saying Elvis had died after
that you can't put to bed for a while
Kelly Marie had a few minor hits in
France was hanging around the office
thought she had a good voice he said
well she's just hanging around the
office it's like one of your stories
they're hanging around the office
when and at lunch time they said could
you sing this she said yeah
and we're good today tell you what Elvis
wouldn't have had the boo boo he would
have been baby
don't give me any of that [ __ ] okay
[Laughter]
man what's in between okay I have a
confession for you I don't really listen
to any cool music it doesn't matter well
are you a podcast a guy that he says he
met and he didn't really matter he just
he just walked through a room yeah that
was sad
yeah
he's pretty funky I've always thought it
was David Bowie could be Bowie or Bowie
I think well I had this argument with my
son and he said boy I said Bowie he
looked up and Bowie said it's Bowie so
it's definitely Bowie because if Bowie
says it's boy it's definitely Bowie I
asked his son I did a film with his son
Duncan Jones and I said to him at dinner
I said is it bully like snowy or is it
Bali like
Bowie
and what did he say he said it's Bowie
like snowy and did you see is it Jones
like bones
what is it Jonas
um
yeah it's a great film that Mooney's
Daydream thing uh it's worth watching
it's kind of it's an interesting film
because it's it's obviously a uh you
know
a biopic you're exploring someone's life
but it doesn't do it I was saying to
bills it doesn't do it in the same way
that we've come to kind of expect which
is like they were born here this is what
their parents did this is how they're
going to music doesn't do that at all
with this it's just like here are some
examples as to why this artist was so
incredible so it's much more like an art
piece like a like slightly experimental
Cinema I loved it that reminds me of one
thing I forgot to ask you you've had
tons of work and done lots of great
stuff and your voice over stuff and and
you're off to New Zealand to do your new
thing but I read somewhere about
something as a documentary about
um Domino yeah what is that oh Domino
rallying oh my god
um it's this documentary called Lily
topples the world and it's have you seen
Lily's YouTube videos no no
um
the most incredible her entire existence
is just loving dominoes and she has
created an Empire where she like builds
these insane domino structures like tens
of thousands of dominoes right and like
videotapes them and she has like she got
a message
why is she doing it because you need a
ton of space don't you yeah so she I
mean she gets hired to do a bunch of
them but does she knock them down is it
wonderful yeah yeah so you can watch
them at the end like she always knocks
them down and did you narrate it no no
no no I just executive produced it yeah
yeah when does that come out it's out
it's out what's it called yeah it's
called Lily topples the world oh
brilliant
in Britain we call that Domino rallying
don't live but are you guys not cool I
didn't know we called it that Domino
Rally didn't know it had the name I
didn't know that either so we definitely
need to see that that's brilliant and
then you're off to New Zealand what are
you going to watch on the flight Lord of
the Rings maybe yeah have you got a
favorite really
um
uh well calendar it's been great to have
you
um have an amazing time in New Zealand
please get in touch if there's some if
you know if you're in a certain city and
you're like hey any ideas like we're not
we're not as good as we used to be but
we're still kind of okay we're still all
right yeah they'll get names in a couple
of restaurants and some people some
friends yeah oh man that is so great I'm
so excited have an amazing time thank
you thank you friends bills we've run
out of time hey everyone I'll get in
touch with us if you want uh what you
don't put that powder in there yeah
cheers
um how can they get in touch with us
well you can rate review And subscribe
to the podcast wherever you're listening
to your podcast and then it's uh the
friendship on you on our YouTube channel
yep if you want merchandise it's the
Friendship onionpodcast.com if we've got
in here we'll give it to you so you can
you can wear it proudly in New Zealand
yeah yes and um if you want to send a
voice message it's uh speakpipe.com
forward slash the Friendship onion
thanks again Kelly Marie hey wonderful
having you
and we'll see you guys next week
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your place
[Music]